الموازين. ويأتي اردوغان ليردها
لبوتين وليست المرة الاولى.
ارض الجديدة. لو دامت لغيرك لما
وصلت اليك تدور الدنيا وتنقلب
مؤتمر استانا وهذه هي المرة
الثالثة هكذا هي سنة الحياة اذا
مع امير قطر ويتم التوقيع على
العديد من الاتفاقيات في مجالات
اوكرانيا مؤكدة ان سفارة الصين
في كييف مستعدة لتقديم المساعدة
الرئيس التركي يجعل نظيره بوتين
ينتظره لاكثر من دقيقتين في
ارتداء النقاب مع غرامة تصل الى
الف دولار على المخالفين يا لهذه
باهتزاز عرش بوتين نرى عرشها في
مهب الريح. فهل من منقذ? سياسة
في تنظيم المغادرة. ها يا للعجب.
سويسرا تعتزم تطبيق قانون يحظر
بنجاح برنامجها الاقتصادي. وماذا
بعد ايها الانجليز? وبعد ان وعدت
الصحة والطاقة والاتصالات والامن
الغذائي فهل تنقذ قطر الاقتصاد
الصاروخية السادسة والعشرين
والتي تجريها بلاده هذا العام.
دعت وزارة الخارجية الصينية
مواطنيها الى مغادرة اراضي
تايوان المركزية ان مسؤولين
اوكرانيين يخططون لزيارة تايوان
العنصرية المقيتة رصيد الناتو من
التحضيرات الروسية اوشك على
الاعداء لوضعهم تحت السيطرة
فبماذا سيرد اعداءه؟ زعيم كوريا
المملكة التي لا تغيب عنها الشمس
يغيب عنها الاقتصاد فيتراجع بذلك
واكدت ان بلادها ستجتاز العاصفة
هنا تحاول تراس انقاذ حكومتها
نهاية الشهر الجاري في غير
محسوبة المخاطر يبدأها مسؤولون
نووية الى سوريا فمن سيجرؤ على
تفتيشها. الحقيقة الكورية
اوكران مع الصين التي تلتزم
الحياد في ازمة اوكرانيا. وقد
لم تعد تنفع والقوة قد غارت
والوضع كما ترون لا كما تسمعون.
كيم ابدى اعجابه وتقديره لوضع
صواريخه وقال الزعيم الكوري ان
واعلنت ترامس ان وزير المالية
الجديد سيقدم خطة لدعم الاقتصاد.
الصواريخ اصابت اهدافها بدقة فهل
من مبارز؟ بريطان تختنق. الحيل
نووية الى سوريا. والهدف بما
وصفته انه تشكيل محيط رادع من
خطواتها بالتضحية بهذا المسئول
الرفيع. نعم لقد اقالت وزير
الذي يجري? تراجع حكومتها عن
الخطة القائمة على خفض الضرائب.
التركي من التراجع? الاحداث
والتطورات. ذكرت وكالة انباء
العدوان الخارجي لكن بشكلها
التقليدي بدون الرؤوس النووية
بعد انزلاق البلاد الى ازمة
اقتصادية وسياسية لتبدأ اولى
الساسة. رئيسة الوزراء
البريطانية جاءت لتغيير الاوضاع
الشمالية قبل البيان بساعات كان
يشرف بنفسه على التجربة
التي جاء بها سلفها بوريس جونسون
وها هي تعود لخطة جونسون فما
السعودي. اما الخطة الروسية التي
قد تكون الاكثر دهاء فهي وبحسب
لتعتذر له بقولها علينا انجاز
مهمتنا بشكل مختلف. ربما كان من
للزالنسكي اكد فيها ابن سلمان ان
بلاده ملتزمة بحل النزاعات
السهل على اقالة وزير الخزانة
لكن من الصعب اقناعها للمتظاهرين
السعودي الروسي. تاتي مكالمة من
ولي العهد السعودي بن سلمان
الشمالية يجري تجاربه للابد وها
هو يعلنها لاعدائه. قواتنا
لان سوريا ليست بلدا نوويا لكن
هل نحن ان بوتين لن يرسل رؤوسا
الشمالية. لا تكفي التجارب وحان
وقت الحقيقة لن يظل مجنون كوريا
النووية جاهزة لحرب نووية فعلية.
هذا البيان من كيم جونغ الى
في تخفيف معاناة الاوكرانيين في
ظل الازمة التي تمر بها البلاد.
وسائل اعلام روسية ان مجلس
الدومة قدم اقتراحا بنقل صواريخ
الاضافية التي قدمتها السعودية
قيمة اربعمائة مليون دولار تسهم
سعادته بالكرم السعودي قائلا.
حزمة المساعدات الانسانية
كما ان ابن سلمان سيساعدنا في
ملف الاسرى. كل هذا السخاء
بالطرق فهل تم هذا الامر بمعرفة
روسية ليخرج زيلنسكي مظهرا
الوثائق اللازمة ذات الصلة في
المستقبل القريب. موسكو تخطط على
ليكمل اردوجان مسيرته وينتقل من
اجتماعه مع ليعقد اجتماعا ثنائيا
لديها معلومات وادلة ملموسة حول
ما جرى لخط انابيب. فهل حان وقت
للقوات الاوكرانية ليأتي الرد من
موسكو قائلة اوروبا تجر نفسها
السعودية حيث صرح نائب رئيس
الوزراء الروسي وقال سيتم تقديم
مخزونها. اما الولايات المتحدة
فتحتاج لسنوات لاعادة مخزونها
موسكو تعلن انها تخطط لتنفيذ اول
مشروع لبناء اول محطة للطاقة في
الاسلحة للناتو تصل لمستوى الخطر
حيث ان واشنطن سلمت كييف ثلث
ظهور الجان الحقيقي? ومن التخطيط
الحربي الى التخطيط المستقبلي.
الى ما قبل حرب اوكرانيا. وذلك
نقلا عن موقع جلودو فاير باور
الى حرب هي ليست ندا لها. فماذا
يقصد الروس هنا لكن يبدو ان دول
مخزونها من صواريخ. والمانيا لا
تكفي ذخيرتها لثمان واربعين ساعة
الناتو لا تتفقد مخازنها ولا
تتفقد الاحصائيات. فمخزونات
فقط في الحرب. وتحتاج برلين الى
اثنين وعشرين مليار يورو لتعويض
هل هي رسالة ام نصيحة? ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي وكأن تهديدات
ان ينفذوا اتفاقات الحلف او ان
يعودوا لمصالح شعبهم. فما هذه?
والعدد. وبين هذا وذاك
الاستخبارات الروسية تصرح. موسكو
وهو الموقع المتخصص بترتيب
الجيوش العالمية من حي العتاد
لتدريب جنود اوكرانيين في بلاده
كجزء من مان مساعدة عسكرية اوسع
المدى البعيد يا سادة. لكن
الغريب في الامر وبعد الاتفاق
بوتين لا تعنيه. وزير الدفاع
البولندي يؤكد ان الاتحاد يخطط
الغزو الروسي ولن يتنازلوا عن
خيرسون ودوندسكوا لوجانسك وشبه
خمسمائة واربعين عسكريا اوكرانيا
خلال اربع وعشرين ساعة ويسبق ذلك
التليفزيوني السابق زيلنسكي ويعد
شعبه بانهم سينتصرون في مواجهة
سادة وهو الامر الذي تؤكده
تقارير استقصائية روسية بان
يومين فقط. يا لهذه الارقام
الضخمة! ليظهر الرئيس والممثل
ايام في المناطق التي سيطرت
عليها موسكو. المعارك تعتدم يا
جزيرة القرمة. هل انت متأكد يا
هذا? وياتي بعده بوتين لكن موجها
فموسكو تجلي المدنيين من خرسون
وتقول سنوفر للجميع سكنا مجانيا
الادخنة وتعود المعارك الى الكر
والفر بين الروس والاوكران.
تحذيرات موسكو بهذه الانظمة فكيف
سيكون الرد الروسي? لتتصاعد
منظومة ناسامز الصاروخية من
واشنطن. بينما واشنطن هنا تتجاوز
وكل ما هو ضروري. في الوقت الذي
اعلن فيه الكرملين القضاء على
روسيا امطرت اوكرانيا بصواريخ
قيمتها نصف مليار دولار.
بانها كانت قد سيطرت على اكثر من
اربعمائة كيلومتر مربع في سبعة
في ازمة اوكرانيا. على الالمان
ان يروا ما هو الاهم بالنسبة لهم
حديثه الى الالمان. قائلا
المانيا اخطأت الى جانب الناتو
وبمشاركة الطائرة الروسية
الخارقة لاول مرة وذلك خلال
للكرملين باعلان بلينكن عن
مساعدة جديدة لاوكرانيا تقدر
ليتزوجوا لخلفوا لهم جيشا يهز
بوتين. يبدو اني خرجت عن النص
الخارجية الروسية فهل كشفت روسيا
اوراق حلف الناتو لتضعه في حيرة
بلدهم من الهجمات الصلبة الروسية
وما اكثر هذه المساعدات! ويا
قليلا. لنكمل. وهنا وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني يعلن تسلم بلاده
منع التصعيد في اوكرانيا لكنه
اختار التصعيد. هكذا قالت
من خطر قد اقترب. تحذيرات لطالما
سمع من الجانب الروسي. لكن اليوم
في حرب اوكرانيا وكل هذا تجاوز
للخط الاحمر. كان بامكان الناتو
كانت المفاجأة باعلان وزارة
الخارجية الروسية ان الناتو هزم
من امره؟ لكن الخارجية الامريكية
كان لها رأي اخر. ووجهت ضربة
لضخامة هذه الارقام! فاذا تم
توزيعها على الشباب العانس
في اوكرانيا. ماذا? نعم فقد
اضافت الوزارة ان الغرب تجاوز خط
بسبعمائة وخمسة وعشرين مليون
دولار لمساعدة الاوكران بحماية
الخطر في هجومه على جسر القرم
وتفجير نوردسترين وتصعيد الناتو
بوجه الناتو. الظلام يخيم على
اجواء اوروبا. وويل لدول الناتو
خطوة غير محسوبة نحو الصين
لينفجر هنا الصينيون غضبا.
وبريطانيا تختنق فهل من منقذ?
بينما اردوغان يجتمع بامير قطر
ليستفز بوتين بهذه الخطوة فهل
هذا جزاء الاحسان واوكرانيا تخطو
ويدعون رعاياهم لسرعة مغادرة
اوكرانيا فورا. التحذير الاخير
الناتو في خطر فما الذي يجري
وزعيم كوريا يصدر اعلانا خطيرا
فيما يقطع وعدا للشعب الاوكراني
وسيناتور امريكي يفضح الرئيس
بينما روسيا تجلي المدنيين من
هذه المدينة بشكل عاجل وفوري.
بايدن وبوتين يعطي المانيا هذه
النصيحة فهل سيعملون بها واسلحة
السماء الاوكرانية. بوتين يبعث
بهدية لابن سلمان تغضب امريكا
فما هو هذا الرد وما الذي يحدث؟
واسلحة روسية جديدة تحلق في
النفاذ وموسكو تستعد لخطوتها
القادمة. فهل هي الحرب يا سادة?